hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American comedy film
called relaxer spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
Abby and cam are a set of weird brothers
from Minnesota they are jobless have no
talent and are hated by all their
neighbors the whole day they play games
and participate in random challenges
hoping to win some cash prize basically
it is the younger brother Abby taking
part in the challenges while the Elder
One cam records him and takes care of
other arrangements kind of like how Ben
Affleck farted in smoked pot while Matt
Damon wrote Goodwill Hunting in the
first scene Abby is playing video games
on his couch with great Focus turns out
this is also a challenge every five
minutes he will have to chug down 100
milliliters of milk within a time frame
of 10 seconds this will continue until
Abby finishes the entire game the
hardest part is that he cannot even get
up from the couch let alone go for a
bathroom break during the challenge Abby
gets tired and thinks of quitting
several times however Kim chastises him
to keep going saying that he is a
quitter who has never done anything good
in his life he also mentions that Abby
quit his recent job because of which
they're in this predicament now they
have no money to buy food or pay pay for
rent so come on Abby keep going until
you poop milk hearing this Abby
reluctantly obligious several hours
later the challenge is still going
strong Abby has completed a substantial
part of the game but his urinary bladder
is almost about to explode he can't hold
it any longer now to gather some
strength he puts on a weird pair of
glasses that his dad had gifted him
years ago from their conversation we get
to know that their dad has been
incarcerated for assaulting a kid Mack
hates him for it and hopes to never see
him again while Abby believes that their
dad is innocent in the next morning Mac
heads to the other room to get something
he wants to spice up the challenge by
adding a few more elements to it taking
advantage of the opportunity Abby grabs
the almost empty gallon of milk and pees
in it after a while Mack returns with
some stuff among which is a magazine he
turns to a page and starts explaining
about a celebrity gamer named Mitchell
the man has apparently reached level 256
of Pac-Man and he has declared an open
challenge anyone who reaches level 257
will be awarded with a cash prize of of
one hundred thousand dollars cam asks
his brother what he will do if he wins
The Challenge to which Abby replies that
he'll buy a private jet buddy 100K can't
even buy you a private toilet as the
tour engrossed in their conversation cam
suddenly realizes that the gallon of
milk is missing he asks Abby about it
and the latter reluctantly brings it out
surprisingly cam is still adamant on
finishing the contents of the gallon
unaware of what his brother has done
Abby tries his best to explain that he
can't drink anymore but cam is having
none of it he wants to continue with the
challenge no matter what so he pours the
content of Abby's bottle and starts
counting down the time the poor guy is
about to drink it but he suddenly starts
puking all over the place this sends the
challenge effectively cam is furious
that he once again berates his brother
for being a quitter he explains that he
rented the camera for an expensive
amount but now he'll have to return it
without any profit these words really
touch Abby so he promises to do another
challenge and this time finish it cam
tells him to take on Mitchell's
challenge which is reaching level 257 of
Pac-Man however during the whole thing
he won't be allowed to get up from the
couch this is a punishment for his
recent failures saying this cam starts
packing his stuff saying he is going to
his friends and he will be back on New
Year's Eve he also reminds Abby that the
camera is recording everything after he
leaves Abby decides to complete the
challenge in his own way he calls his
friend Dallas and asks him to bring
pizza drinks and a movie an hour later
Dallas arrives at the door and
immediately starts complaining about the
foul stench coming from the room he also
makes fun of Abby for being an
unemployed person who thinks challenges
are some way of earning money he then
delivers some painful news he couldn't
bring the pizza because his
ex-girlfriend was there and he didn't
want to face her that's tough Dallas
says Abby my brother chains me to the
couch and makes me pee milk hearing this
though Abby asks him to Simply get a
sandwich from the freezer Dallas
complies but before handing it over he
makes sure to chew a good bite out of
the sandwich Dallas also refuses to hand
over the drinks he brought saying he
wants to be paid for them first Abby
insists that he is very thirsty but
Dallas doesn't change his mind instead
he decides to use them for a challenge
of his own Dallas tapes the bottles of
drinks to both his hands and starts
performing weird moves at this point
Abby has had enough so he wears his
glasses and stares at his creepy friend
in Anger surprisingly this causes the
Caps of the drinks to blow off Dallas is
taken aback by the incident and he
starts wondering if the glasses have
super powers when Abby doesn't reply he
pours most of the drinks on the floor
what what the hell dude following this
he plays the movie he brought and it
turns out to be a cartoon expectedly
this enrages Abby and he calls Dallas
out for being a useless brat who
couldn't bring any of the things he had
asked for he is just a jerk who likes to
make fun of people after he calms down
Abby asks Dallas to put the video game
back on so that he can continue with the
challenge the latter does as asked and
finally prepares to leave but before
going out however he throws one of the
bottles towards Abby it contains little
to nothing but our protagonist cherishes
it like the there's no tomorrow that
night after all his supplies have run
out hubby tries to retrieve a cup from
the floor without standing he uses a
selfie stick to get the job done but
unfortunately the cop contains a lot of
cockroaches so now Abby will have to
spend the night hungry and thirsty at
least Abby's not playing Miss Pac-Man
that'd make him real thirsty the next
morning two fumigators arrived there to
wake him up they want to fill the place
with insecticide gas and kill all the
pests that have been bothering the
nearby tenants then they ask Abby to
step out but as expected he refuses
after being a quitter all his life he is
adamant on finishing this challenge one
way or another unfortunately the guys
are having none of it so they lift the
couch and take him outside with no
options left Abby promises to give half
his earnings to them once he wins The
Challenge the guys find it hard to
believe what kind of an idiot would make
us a deal like that but nonetheless they
let him be shortly after they spray the
whole apartment with poisonous
insecticides and leave Abby is still on
his couch he is put on a face mask and
is munching on some leftover sandwich
you found on the floor he tries playing
for a while but soon passes out due to
extreme fatigue and dehydration that
night one of his friends Aaron arrives
and wakes him up she is surprised to see
him in this state and asks why the
lights are off Abby replies that they
stopped working now he is giving it all
to complete Mitchell's challenge how's
the game working if the lights aren't
hearing this Aaron becomes even more
surprised saying that reaching level 257
in Pac-Man is impossible there is a
glitch on the 256th level which makes
sure no one can cross it however Abby is
still hopeful he wants to at least try
because he needs the money to meet his
incarcerated dad as the two continue
talking Aaron's co-worker Cortez arrives
at the door he seems to be an arrogant
man who likes bullying others he
immediately starts complaining about the
foul smell coming from the room and asks
Erin to come with him when she asks for
some more time he begins provoking the
half-naked gamer Cortez reveals that
Abby's father is a child assaulter who
has never done anything good in his life
he was caught red-handed inside a gas
station but he still has no remorse
about it however Abby does not stay
silent he says that his father was an
honest and hard-working man who was
framed by evil people he was only trying
to help the girl at the gas station but
the authorities perceived him in the
wrong way despite the clarification
Cortez continues bullying him having had
enough Abby finally snaps and puts on
the special glasses he then gives Cortez
a menacing look because of which the
latter starts feeling slight pain in his
chest fortunately before things got out
of control Aaron stops him she then
angrily leaves the place with a friend
promising to never come back again and
Abby is slightly upset not because his
friend is leaving him but because she
didn't bring any food for him
nonetheless he brushes it aside and
resumes playing the next morning Abby
wakes up in a cold sweat he is extremely
dehydrated due to the lack of fluid in
his body to make matters worse he is
also choking because of all the windows
in the room being closed since Abby has
nothing to consume he simply licks some
sweat from his body hoping it can
re-energize happy out here thinking he's
on the planet arrakis the plan works and
once Abby gets some of his energy back
he tries reaching for the window to open
it since he cannot get up he uses
various objects around him but none of
them work at last he reverts to his
biggest weapon his glasses Abby puts
them on and signals the window to open
itself unfortunately he miscalculates
his powers and ends up breaking the
window glass through which a dead bird
suddenly enters after checking out the
bird Abby realizes that it is raining
outside so he tries to gather some rain
water through the window he uses a
camera tripod but the plan fails
miserably at this point Abby has become
so desperate that he starts collecting
the tiny droplets of water seeping
through the walls however it soon stops
raining and the droplets disappear
frustrated he once again calls Dallas
and tries manipulating him into bringing
some food Abby explains that they're
going to play a new challenge in which
they have to eat a pizza inside five
minutes sadly Dallas finds out about the
deceit and hangs up the call the fact
that you're gonna die isn't a good
enough excuse dude making the half Naked
Gamer completely Delirious in a fit of
rage he smashes some stuff around him
later Abby thinks of an idea he has seen
a water pipe on the wall from outside so
he calculates the exact spot and starts
banging on it with his tripod he manages
to find a pipe but it is the wrong one
Abby accidentally struck the toilet pipe
and now the dirty substance is filling
his room still he doesn't stop trying
and continues striking the wall a while
later his hard work finally pays off and
he is able to find the drinking water
pipe in the next scene we are shown that
Abby is still inside the room on his
couch playing the video game however
drastic ramifications have been made to
his surroundings first of all he has
grown a long beard indicating that it
has been a long while since he got off
the couch the window is still open so he
usually kills birds and Cooks them for
food as for the water he still has that
Unlimited Supply to summarize Abby looks
like a caveman one night as he is
playing his neighbor starts celebrating
an occasion by launching fireworks in
the sky Abby uses this as motivation so
he puts on the glasses and starts
playing with all his Focus surprisingly
he manages to beat the supposed
impossible level 256 of Pac-Man Abby
celebrates the success alone thinking
that he is some kind of God the next
morning cam finally arrives at the
apartment with a friend he is shocked to
find his brother still sitting on the
couch when asked Abby reveals that he
has completed Mitchell's Challenge and
is now looking for a much more difficult
one he then asks what day it is to which
cam responds that they just celebrated
the 4th of July last night that means
that Abby sat on the couch for more than
six months as the two continue talking
cam reveals that their dad passed away
because the outside world had become
catastrophic crimes have increased
global warming has taken a turn for the
worse and people have started eating
each other their dad was also probably
eaten by someone just then Cam finds one
of his brother's Birds which he has kept
in a box it is a decomposing half-eaten
bird yet Abby calls it his pet disgusted
cam starts making fun of it enraging
Abby so to teach his brother brother a
lesson he finally gets up from the couch
and uses his telekinetic Powers his
glasses also start glowing because of
which cam feels a sudden pain in his
head the next second his head explodes
into Smithereens splattering blood all
over Abby with this our gamer
protagonist has completed yet another
challenge he has now been drenched in
literally all the bad stuff sweat vomit
P insecticide excrete and blood all he's
missing is that goop from Nickelodeon in
the final scene someone comes through
the door which makes Abby smile for the
first time in months he slowly hands
over his favorite knife to the person
possibly his dad subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching